christine is going to start off this
hour in Scranton Pennsylvania hi
Christine how are you hi how are you
today Dave better than I deserve what's
up in your world I'm calling because
about two years ago we decided to get on
your plan and in the beginning we
weren't very confident in ourselves me
and my husband so we had my
mother-in-law helping us out with it and
we had decided to open up an account in
her name and all of our income would be
deposited into this account but she
would help us with you know getting on
the plan and budgeting and stuff like
that well we moved from New Jersey to
Pennsylvania and we've made the decision
to buy a house but the problem is is
when we're trying to get a mortgage and
get the ones like Churchill offers they
they will not accept the income from the
previous two years because it wasn't out
of our bank account so we're wondering
another way we can prove to the banks
that we do make the income and we can
afford a mortgage and how to get a
mortgage tax returns two years or two
years of your tax returns should do it
just give them the tax devices don't
they want to see us paying bills on time
yeah they'd like to see you better
having paid your landlord on time early
or on time and you could provide a lease
that proves that the lease was in your
name I don't know if this is going to
work because you've not been operating
as if you have a life yeah and and I
hope you've made the transfer to where
you're now managing your own money
of course yeah this is a really bad idea
okay for a lot of reasons but this is
the part of the problem with it you know
yeah I I don't know I mean you may it
may be two years but you may have to
establish a a landlord payments record
out of a checking account that you own
for two years that may have that may
happen but you can you can prove your
income with your tax returns yes but we
can't prove that payments that we were
making to our landlord out of her
anything else for that matter exactly on
traditional credit for instance cable
company and everything else because
all out of her account so I don't know
if you'll be able to pull that off
Churchill can walk you through it and
tell you but my guess is is that this is
delayed you buying a home on a mortgage
anyway which might not be all bad you
just save up a little more for a down
payment and rent something inexpensively
the good news is you got you've stopped
the mess and it's now in your name and
so and you can control your your money
in your future from this point forward
you